all right let's talk about Saladin
salahudin the great Muslim hero who
annihilated the evil
Crusaders and uh see how he fits into
the construct of fake history which I
recently discussed about the Crusades
and how fake history Works basically
fake history like fake news uh is a
distortion of the past and it creates
these overarching narratives and then
things in the present are completely
misunderstood intentionally so because
they're connected to this this false
fake history so Saladin uh who lived in
the 12th century and is famous for
defeating the Crusaders at the Battle of
hatin and for conquering Jerusalem from
the Crusaders and expelling them and
beating them in many more battles before
and after um and he's a great hero
obviously for that amongst Muslims but
he's also a Great Hero amongst
westerners and Christians for some
reason so let's discuss that anywhere
you look if you watch a movie such as a
kingdom of heaven but also in books and
this goes all the way back to uh Sir
Walter Scott Ivan ho the Talisman these
types of novels where Saladin figures
and he's presented essentially as a
chivalrous Knight um and it's also
amongst academics and Scholars and so
forth let me give you some examples in a
recent website which a friend sent to me
uh christianity.com it's also about
Saladin and it presents him as
magnanimous merciful moderate a paragon
of virtue in an era marred by Crusader
brutality etc etc and then this
following quote appears Saladin shamed
the ruthless Crusaders by treating the
city with kindness and keeping every
promise he made to its people when he
conquered Jerusalem in 11
1187 saladin's courage Justice and
moderation were rare in that age and
have won him lasting respect in the west
the Crusaders did not live up to
Christ's teachings about love after they
had conquered the Middle East what a
different Tale the Crusaders might have
told if they had at least lived up to
saladin's code even if they were unable
to abide by the law of love so this sort
of thing is common here's another quote
by um onetime esteemed American
historian Dana Carlton Monroe died in
1933 so as you can see this sort of
thing goes a while back this is almost a
century now and he writes quote when we
contrast with this the Crusader conquest
of Jerusalem before saladan in 1099 the
conduct of saladan when he captured
Jerusalem from the Christian in 1187 we
have a striking illustration of the
difference between the two civilizations
Muslims and Christians and realize what
the Christians might learn from contact
with the sarasin in the holy land no
might learn not might have learned
present tense so what's the big deal let
saladan have some Fame and glory and be
respected in the west well the problem
again uh to go back to the topic of fake
history is this Saladin according to the
Muslim sources is also portrayed as a
very religious and devout Muslim now if
he was according to the Western version
peaceful moderate um this Paragon of
virtue and magnanimity etc etc and he
was a observant Muslim an observant
Muslim then clearly what we have today
radicals extremist Isis we can't say
that they're mainstream Muslims at best
they're aberration because we have
fellows like Saladin who was a sultan
powerful Rich influential and he read
the Quran regularly and prayed and
fasted as his biographers say yet he was
magnanimous and merciful etc etc
therefore we can no longer say or even
argue that groups like Isis and the
radicals are representative of
mainstream Islam again at best they're
an aberration now back to some real
history about Saladin according again to
his own biographers and he's well
recorded he had a whole Entourage that
followed him around and they wrote about
him he was every bit like Isis in fact
Isis learned some tactics from Saladin
we can say the famous choreographed
videos of them with Christians cops
Ethiopians and anyone victims in front
of them in the orange jumpsuits where
they stand behind them knock them over
pull their heads back and carve their
heads off that was straight from
saladin's Playbook at the Battle of
Hatton that's exactly what he did he
allowed various Crusaders to Ransom
themselves because he's magnanimous but
the Knights of the temple and the
hospital because they were the most
committed Crusaders against against the
Jihad even the Muslims point this out he
he gave them one option convert to Islam
and fight for him they all rejected it
and he had them all paraded in front of
his army and um that's where you get the
Isis thing all these men stood in the
back all these Muslims who were so eager
to be given the chance to carve the head
off of the infidels as the sources relay
stood behind them knocked them over
started carving their heads and
screaming Allah abbar and the sources
relay that saladan sat back on his
throne with a huge smile
all right doesn't sound very moderate to
me sounds very Isis like even his taking
of Jerusalem which all these people who
like to extol Saladin uh point to as I
as I mentioned in those quotes is not
what you think because he didn't free
they often tell you that the Crusaders
in 1099 when they conquered Jerusalem
committed a blood bath whereas salad and
peacefully allowed the Christians to
withdraw not true he tried to besiege
them he threatened at one point when
they offered uh to surrender he said no
I'm going to have you all slaughtered
then they said we're going to slaughter
all our Muslim captives destroy Alam
mosque and completely destroy Jerusalem
for you and then he decided okay fine
surrender and I'll let you go but unlike
the Western histories the Muslim
histories say that 15,000 of the poor
Crusaders who could not Ransom
themselves he consigned to slavery and
about seven or8 thousand of those were
women and children and once again we
have to turn to the Muslim eyewitness
accounts to see what really happened
there so for for example Muhammad Al
Isani one of saladin's Entourage who was
there at the capitulation of Christian
Jerusalem he wrote quote Women and
Children Together came to 8,000 and we
and were quickly divided up among us as
slaves bringing a smile to Muslim faces
at their lamentation he thereafter
launches into a rather sat masochistic
tyde extolling the sexual debasement of
European women at the hands of Muslim
men a not unfamiliar phenomena today and
he writes quote how how many
well-guarded women were profaned and
miserable women forced to yield
themselves and women who had been kept
hidden meaning nuns stripped of their
modesty and free women occupied meaning
penetrated and precious ones used for
hard work and pretty things put to the
test and virgins Dishonored and proud
women deflowered and happy ones made to
weep so that's what really happened in
the Arabic Chronicles of the time
written by eyewitnesses meanwhile you
hear of course of the wonderful mag
unanimous
Saladin and we can go on and on
saladin's retirement dream was
essentially after he hoped to evict the
Crusaders entirely from the holy land
and he nearly succeeded but didn't and
his retirement dream if he succeeded was
to wage Jihad on Christian Europe until
quote there shall not remain on the face
of the this Earth One Infidel in Allah
or I will die in the
attempt again more examples if his
quarrel was with the Crusaders about
land let's say and it wasn't something
religious didn't have religious uh
chauvinism to it it wasn't about anti-
christianism why is it the weak and
outnumbered and the defenseless
Christians who did live under his rule
as the cops of Egypt where he was Sultan
why are they always being attacked
according to the records he had them
crucified burned mauled their churches
he had them tarred with dirt uh if they
were too white crosses broken
etc
etc again the point of all this isn't to
be smch the popularity of Saladin per se
but rather to give you an example again
of how fake history works again to
reiterate he is this magnanimous Sultan
the way he's portrayed in the west then
so-called radical Islam of today has to
be seen as at best an
aberration yet in reality and here's the
irony if you understand the true Saladin
the one that I've just described to you
then actually when you look at Isis and
these groups they fit in a perfect
Continuum that stretches back to Saladin
indeed that stretches back to Muhammad
the prophet of Islam